[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
are going to be talking about one of the
most iconic villains in the entire
Dragon Ball franchise the galactic
Overlord Frieza as a kid I was a massive
fan of Dragon Ball Z when it first aired
in North America in the early 2000 and
Frieza always stuck with me as the most
memorable villain I thought that the
freezer saga was the most interesting
saga and I still remember when Goku
transformed into a Super Saiyan for the
very first time during his final
showdown with Frieza on Namek as soon as
that episode ended I ran straight to my
friends house to share the experience
with him and that was definitely the
highlight of the entire series for me
now that the Galactic tyrant is back and
stronger than ever in Dragon Ball super
we thought it would be a good idea to
make a video explaining all of his many
forms and transformation be sure to let
me know who your favorite villains are
in the Dragon Ball franchise down below
if you would like to see more videos
about the Dragon Ball universe on this
channel be sure to smash that like
button like it was Crillon space and if
you are new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell and now let's get into it
not only is Frieza a member of a
powerful race but he is also a mutant
with an incredibly high level of power
which makes him and his family by far
the most powerful members of their
mysterious race Frieza especially had
such immense amounts of natural power
that he never had to actually train or
overcome any major challenges and yet he
still became one of the most powerful
beings in the entire universe in fact
before the rise of the Super Saiyan the
only being that Frieza could not
challenge in the entirety of universe 7
was beus the god of destruction himself
it is also interesting to note that
without Frieza
none of the events of the entire Dragon
Ball franchise would ever have happened
it was due to freezes policies and
actions that kal-el weight diving
Kakarot was sent to earth before the
destruction of his home planet setting
all the events of the entire series into
motion the
in ball series creator akira toriyama
was partially inspired to create Frieza
by the actions of predatory real-estate
investors in Japan except instead of
taking over homes and businesses Frieza
took control of entire planet and his
empire is believed to have encompassed
over 400 different planets and now for
the transformations in the world of
Dragon Ball transforming is the ability
to take on a different physical form
that allows access to higher levels of
power Frieza has multiple forms and
transformations both organic and
artificial and we will discuss them all
here in his very first form Frieza looks
like a small pink and purple demon with
a long tail at horn he is also primarily
seen in his hover pod or flying chair
and to me as a kid watching Dragon Ball
Z for the first time freezes appearance
in his first form combined with his
voice in the English dub reminded me of
an evil old lady but that only made him
even scarier when we realized the extent
of his power and of course even in this
form and sitting comfortably in his
hover pod he was able to destroy all of
Planet Vegeta without any trouble using
his super nova death beam his power
level in this form is known to be
530,000 to put that into perspective
think about how shot Vegeta was when he
saw that Goku's power level had reached
over 8,000 or 9,000 in the English
version by contrast breezes power level
in his first and weakest form is more
than 60 times higher than Goku's at that
point but that is only scratching the
surface of freezes true power in his
second form Frieza turns into a hawkish
version of his first form he becomes
taller and far more muscular and he
sheds his artificial armor as it can no
longer contain his massive frame in this
form freezes power level doubles to over
1 million Frieza third form makes him
look less human and more alien his head
becomes elongated and his face changes
so that he no longer has a nose it's
pretty safe to say that this form was
directly inspired by the alien from the
air
movie franchise in this form Frieza is
known to use the crazy finger beam
attack which allows him to fire multiple
death beams at once in rapid succession
causing incredible damage but even this
terrifying form does not represent the
true extent of freezes power then we
arrive at freezes final form or at least
we think it says final form at this
point in this final form Frieza goes
back to a smaller size and he loses his
horns this is his true form the form
that he was actually born in and unlike
Super Saiyans who reached higher forms
in order to become stronger Frieza
created his previous three forms as a
way of lowering and conserving his power
because in his true form he is so strong
that being in it for a long time will
drain his stamina but even in this final
form Frieza is able to hold back much of
his power he fights Goku at only 50% of
his ultimate power until Goku first
turns into a Super Saiyan at 50%
strength in his final form freezes power
level is 60 million and at 100% strength
his power level reaches an incredible
120 million according to the Dragon Ball
encyclopedia due to the fact that he
never had to use it since all of his
previous opponents were far too weak
Frieza never learned to master his final
form the reason Super Saiyan Goku is
able to defeat him on Namek is that
Frieza allows himself to take too much
damage before reaching 100% strength and
this weakens his body so that when he
doesn't reach 100% power he is unable to
stay at that level for long for this
reason his body eventually becomes
overwhelmed and the fact that he never
bothered to train and master his true
form is the primary reason why Goku is
ultimately able to defeat Frieza after
his defeat all Namek Frieza is on the
brink of death but he is found in his
severely injured state by his father
king cold and infused with cybernetic
parts which not only save his life but
also make him even stronger than he was
before Frieza feels so humiliated and
angry after his defeat to goku that he
sets out for earth to get revenge as
soon as his recovery is complete
it is believed that in his mecha form
Frieza is powerful enough to generate a
death ball that is 10 times stronger
than the one he used to destroy the
planet namek but we do not get to see
mecha Frieza in action for long because
once he arrives on earth he is quickly
destroyed by Future Trunks after his
death at the hands of Future Trunks
reason is eventually revived by his
henchmen using the power of the Dragon
Balls still obsessed with getting
revenge against Goku and now back in his
organic body Frieza actually dedicates
themselves to training in order to get
stronger and as a result he becomes the
first person to unlock the ultimate form
of his race the golden form golden
Frieza is taller than his previous form
and his body is now covered in an
organic golden armor this form is even
stronger than his original final form
and his power surpasses the Super Saiyan
blue forms of Goku and Vegeta however it
quickly becomes clear that Frieza cannot
sustain himself in his golden form for a
long period of time his golden form
expend so much energy that it drains his
stamina which eventually forces him to
revert back to his true form even though
he is able to attain incredible power in
his golden form especially when he
becomes angry he simply cannot control
it effectively as was the case during
his battle with Super Saiyan Goku on
Namek it appears that Frieza did not
train enough in his final form to be
able to control it he was too anxious to
exact his revenge on Goku and he didn't
take the time to perfect his golden form
and this once again leads to his defeat
this is a lesson that the Dragon Ball
series teaches us over and over again
people like Frieza who are born with
power and never face big challenges get
cocky they get complacent and this leads
to their downfall on the other hand the
Saiyans who must face challenges and
battle more powerful opponents
throughout their lives become stronger
as a result of these challenges and this
allows them to win out in the end well
as long as they have a god of
destruction and time-travel on their
side devastated after yet another defeat
Rize
dedicates his time in health to training
in order to master his
four through exhausted mental training
he learns to control and focus his
immense energy which allows him to
become a better fighter and reach even
greater levels of power in his golden
form Frieza calls this state true golden
Frieza his golden form after he is able
to master it in order to unlock its full
potential we are yet to witness the true
extent of his power but we can look
forward to that
during the universe survival saga in
Dragon Ball super and who knows maybe
even beyond that and that is it all
freezes forms and transformations in
Dragon Ball Z and Dragon Ball super
there are additional transformations
that we can attain and storylines that
are not in continuity with the main
story such as in the Dragon Ball Z video
games but for the purposes of this video
I thought it would be best to stick to
the main story of the anime if you
enjoyed this video be sure to go
supernova on that like button and if you
want to see more videos like this don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell also feel free to let
me know what type of Dragon Ball related
videos you would like to see in the
future as always thank you so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]